all right it's from daily wire country
music star Jason Aldean's wife Brittany
an outspoken opponent of the woke agenda
permeating much in American society
fired back at critics of her husband's
song try that in a small town called the
lyrics racist Aldine song released in
May was targeted uh by people saying it
was racist and pro-lynching we talked
about that yesterday
um she wrote on her Instagram story
media it's the same song and dance twist
everything you can to fit your repulsive
narrative how about instead of creating
stories we focus on the real ones such
as child trafficking food for thought
um and this is after Aldean defended
himself we played some of his statement
yesterday
um so far neither Jason Aldean or his
wife are backing down or apologizing and
I give him credit for that because
usually the way these things go you know
we're going on uh like 48 hours now of
Jason Aldean being accused of being a
pro-lynching racist
by everyone in the media and uh and on
social media and the outrage mob coming
after it's like 48 hours if not more of
this and what we find typically is that
uh people don't last even
usually it's like two or three hours is
kind of the maximum and then we get the
full-throated apology the retraction and
everything else that hasn't happened yet
I I really hope it stays that way
um
uh it has to
and I think Jason Aldean and Brittany
Aldi I think they understand that um
first of all it's wrong to back down on
your convictions to begin with but also
it doesn't do you any good
so you you've been branded a racist
who's in favor of lynching
and once they've said that and they've
said that to begin with with it there's
no basis for it to begin with so there's
nothing you can say that's going to
dissuade them or persuade them otherwise
there's nothing you could say that would
make that make them go you know what
maybe they're not okay with lynching
maybe that maybe the country song was
not a call to round up black people and
Lynch them there's not there's nothing
you could say that would make them
respond that way because it was never
based in fact to begin with
and I think the aldeans uh understand
all of that so I do have
a fair amount of faith that they're
going to stick by their stick by their
guns on this and and I certainly hope
they do a few years ago I sent in a
portrait photo uh to paint your life and
the process quick and easy I love their
work so much I decided to use them again
as you all know aliens are very real I
was able to capture a photo of me
greeting aliens as they came to Earth
this really happened I was able to
easily send in this photo in about two
weeks this will be turned into the most
beautiful realistic oil painting those
who are actually doing this it I mean
the real stories they asked me what
painting I want from paint your life and
I said I wanna I want a painting of me
meeting aliens and I wasn't sure if they
would really do it but apparently they
are because it's in the copy so I'm
super excited about this if you're
looking for a unique gift idea you also
need to check out pink life and I said I
want it as big as possible I'm gonna
because I'm gonna bring it home not tell
my wife any of this
um so you know this is this is my this
is my next Salvo uh we know what
happened on Johnny The Walrus now I'm
bringing home a giant painting of me
green eating aliens and we're gonna put
it right above the fireplace mantle
anyway they create hand-painted
portraits that fit almost any budget and
are great gift ideas for those you love
upload photos to create anything you
imagine put yourself in a location
you've always wanted to go to or had a
lost loved one to a special occasion to
create the portrait of your dreams maybe
I can add a lost loved one to this
picture of aliens that's probably it's
too far you could choose the uh the
artist art medium uh and they have great
selection of quality frames as well
their user friendly platform lets you
order a custom made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes
they'll get your professional
hand-painted portrait in as little as
two weeks there's no risk if you don't
love the final painting I know I'm gonna
love mine they'll give you a full refund
right now paint your life is offering
our listeners 20 off plus free shipping
text Matt to 87204 that's Matt 287204
paint your life and celebrate them the
moments that matter most if you want
some positive news in the culture War
since Roe v Wade was overturned the left
has lost their mind making abortion
their official Sacrament the pro-life
efforts which are more important now
than ever are booming you heard that
right despite the narrative pro-lifers
did not go away they've only increased
in number it's one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post Rural America 40 Days for life
is changing hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States they've had a
record number of locations since Roe was
overturned and they grew in both
volunteers and locations with about 1
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful Angels outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal Battles by protecting free
speech for their volunteers by giving a
tax-deductible gift of any amount at
40daysforlife.com that's 40
daysforlife.com you know one other note
about this and we talked about this
plenty yesterday so we don't need to
rehash it
um but
one of the one of the points that I've
seen people make about the try that in a
small town song why it's racist and I've
even seen I don't know why I say even
like this is surprising but I've even
seen
some conservatives on Twitter
um who who are
uh conceding that the song is troubling
and one of the things that they find
troubling about it is that allegedly
apparently
the the building you know in the music
video
uh Jason Aldean is singing in front of
us a building some building in Tennessee
and that that building was they claim
the site of an actual lynching
and so oh it's that's the messaging that
he's sending this is subliminal messages
he went to the site of an actual
lynching and sang this song
yeah as if and I didn't even look it up
to see if it's true or not because it's
it's irrelevant
because if it is true then it was uh
what they're saying was a hundred years
ago a century ago
allegedly a lynching happened uh outside
this building
so so they're supposed so before you you
shoot a music video You're supposed to
look at all the buildings there in the
background and do a detailed uh
historical dive to find out if anything
bad happened at any point anywhere in
the vicinity of where you're doing the
music video
give me a as if they're supposed to know
that right and all you know these people
on Twitter pretending that they oh well
that that's the infamous site of the
lynching of uh of 19 whatever
as if you already knew that as if you
saw the building and immediately wrecked
oh that was where that Infamous lynching
happened 103 years ago oh shut up
you had no idea
one person went on Wikipedia or
somewhere and found this so we got him
now and then everybody else sees it and
says oh yeah well I knew that what you
didn't know that building was a lynching
happen there 103 everyone knows that he
must have known that it's common
knowledge
it's common knowledge now because
they're all pretending
um
and that's why the whole thing is so
flimsy and so ridiculous that uh it's
just it's based in absolute fantasy the
claims they're making about the song are
and um
so the only thing that we should get
from the aldeans towards the outrage mob
is utter contempt
if anything if I have any note you know
for them on their reaction so far and
again it's been good but if anything
like turn up the contempt a little bit
more
um because these people deserve it they
they desperately deserve it if you'd
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed